hi I'm Tony Sargent and today I'd like
to talk about maybe my career so far in
martial arts and perhaps and things that
you can relate to as well
I'm they'll separate at the age of 17
and I started Aikido when I was 23 I
then also I've done Taichi being a
chilling out for that learn yoga teacher
and health
meditation massage healing and yes I've
had a very full life so far and my
thoughts about my Kido is what I'd like
to say I was I fell into everything
really none of them was were desired
from me they won't buy troubles I
happened to be there or somebody talked
me into going and before I knew it I was
immersed in the different arts I'd like
to talk about Aikido really on this
first video one because the concept
around the world is that
Aikido really isn't a self-defense and
looking at the Aikido traveling the five
continents of the world I I tend to
agree with that sadly it's guy a whole
proportion of what it started to be and
most people now because the majority are
doing the flowing style of Aikido styles
the martial side is really limited to
very few dojos have dotted around the
world I would hope to think that we
think that we
quite unique but perhaps we're missing
something as well and the flying styles
do have a lot depending on what you're
looking for in life really I think if
you're looking for more of a spiritual
path exercise well-being understanding
of others then the flowing styles are
really good for that if you want to rely
upon it in the world in the streets of
the world as a martial art of
self-defense to look after you and your
loved ones around you most of them think
99 percent of them wouldn't work and
that's perhaps why they've got a bad
name and why people have gone to to MMA
and a few of the more fighting arts
because that that they're real is
competitive and you get results and when
when you see Aikido being to walk or
demonstrated after watching what the
films produced over the last twenty
thirty years
we just can't compete you know we're
normal people with some very good skills
but we don't have a camera crew with big
crash mats set up stunt people doing our
doubles and making it look like the body
can do superhuman things and annihilate
dozens of people so when we look at the
films even myself we tend to think it
looks real and we enjoy them and why not
and then when somebody sees a
demonstration like he don't even if it's
the March
scientists although I do we call it you
are my star you are my real means the
Obama school the original one that
essentially produced after the Second
World War
even that doesn't look anywhere near the
Bruce leads the Jason Stratton gently
you know just a quick few because they
are all set now the founder moved to a
small village in Japan called you AMA
that's hence the name of the style he
set it up an in that because being a
small village in a rural environment the
people that come to train with them were
mainly railway workers the farm workers
so very physical very strong why called
the no-neck people very powerful in the
moment so to move them and throw them
you had to also be very powerful except
very sensi he found a way where he could
do his eye his art on them and in tell
him break them down so they understood
that strength is a record but to take
someone's balances so a lot of people
criticize me for one saying because they
think that the flowing style is the star
the original style the original style
was actually Yoshi cannon and that was
before the Second World War but after
the Second World War the government
Center
all martial arts must be banned and so
ever since the Millea movie Sheba was
his name he had to soften it and sake so
they couldn't really call it martial art
it is a martial art but it was
discolours very through fluid movements
and exercises he had to the other son
but and who was supposed to take it over
but sadly he died and so it was put upon
his other son who was more of an
academic and lived in Tokyo to take on
the role of carrying on his work and
I'll talk about that in the next section
if you have any questions so far please
just pop them down and that's the whole
point of this questions and answers and
I'll make the programs to fit your
thoughts okay